Jeff starts off this hour in Phoenix
Arizona hi Jeff how are you I'm good
better than I deserve what's up okay I
just wanted to get your take on some of
them struggling with a little bit
regarding prenups and kind of the
biblical you know thought process on it
as well as obviously the logical is I've
struggled back and forth a little bit
but been in a relationship for a while
looking at getting married we're both
much older you know in our later is 40s
both obviously have assets and children
from previous relationships and looking
to try to you know merge that together
and so on how many how much assets do
you have I have about 850 what about her
about a hundred thousand okay
what's your income mine a little over
150 how old are you I'm 50 years old and
how old is she forty-eight okay well let
me just come I don't have any real hard
and fast thing on it generally spent and
I think you'd be hard-pressed to make a
quote biblical case for or against
except that you know the Bible is pretty
much clear that when you get married
that's it you're gonna have to take a
bullet for them and so if you're not
willing to you know I'm better for worse
you know the old Book of Common Prayer
you remember the old old-fashioned
marriage vows in rich in sickness and
health rich or for poor unto the all my
worldly goods I pledge that's the
ancient you know very very ancient
process and and would be steeped in
biblical tradition I'm not sure I can
back it up biblically completely but I
think the concept is there that you're
all-in and I don't think disagree with
that so I I generally have said avoid
prenups and I run into absurd situations
like one girl called and said you know
this boy she was dating wanted to prenup
because he had a a rehabbed all the way
from the frame 67 Chevelle and he wanted
to you know protect her from taking it
were they to get a divorce and I said
this guy do not marry him he likes cars
more than you
you know so this is you know that's an
absurd thing that's kind of obvious for
most people with common sense to go no
you don't need a prenup you need a new
boyfriend and so you know that kind of
thing so but but in your case you know
as it starts to go I used to just want
to first started all this 20 years ago
I'm babbling but because it's such an
interesting topic but 20 years ago I
used to say no never do a prenup if you
don't love them mourn you love money
don't marry you
that was my stance and generally I'm
gonna go there most of the time I'll
tell you what softened me on it though
the only thing softened me on it is I've
worked with so many these athletes and
I've worked with so many these music
people where you know they've got 10
million bucks and they're getting
married somebody doesn't have two
nickels
and obviously somebody been hanging
around the football team hello you know
it's like it's like hanging around with
Docs cuz you want to hitch one you know
hook one and so you know in those
situations where there's an extreme
disparity and there's a lot of money on
the line it's not that the principal
doesn't apply it's just I and usually
it's not even the person they're
marrying that's nuts
but those people that they're marrying
have nuts in their lives yeah they're
squirrels around them and that think
that all of a sudden then that that boys
supposed to pay for her Momma's House or
something and it just gets it's crazy
people and the amount of money makes it
crazy so in those situations I actually
do recommend a prenup but in a
traditional marriage situation no you're
kinda in the middle of that you own the
bubble because I obviously you know I
took years old I've got 15 17 years left
before hopefully retirement and I'm sure
that I've got enough money to provide
for myself and you know all of those
sorts of things and you know would you
give 400 grand to be married to this
lady yeah that's what it boils down to I
guess yeah I guess I didn't look at it
that way but that's another way of
saying it and and and is that gonna you
know that the only part of your story
that that that that gave me a little bit
of pause was the you've both got kids
from formers correct and and you want to
somehow do that and you can do that with
trust
or with you know some other stuff maybe
not the prenups maybe not the vehicle
but man I tell you I want to be sure I
date them long enough that I'm willing
to invest that heavily I mean I've told
Sharon my wife man if I die you know
she's good-looking she'll get married
quick probably if she wants to you know
and she's gonna be unbelievably rich so
uh you know she's just danger it's just
a danger she needs a prenup you know and
to protect my kids that kind of thing so
anyway that's that comes into play I
would say you're on the bubble and I
would tread very carefully and warily
and I would be scared about the prenup
because it's a bad thing in general but
in some cases just make sure you're not
just make sure that you're willing to
pay a price for that wife man if you're
not willing to pay a price for her
that's that's more than gold then then
you're not ready for marriage yet yeah
that's the that's the acid test I keep
coming back to and I think you're that
guy that's why I'm talking to you this
way I think you're the guy that's gonna
do that yeah well like I said it's it's
one of the things you've been going back
and forth with and trying to make sure I
make the right decision and I'm no help
cuz I didn't have a right way I didn't
give another talk but you gave me a lot
of insight and and like I said I think
that you gotta look at kids and all the
other stuff and you know it's like I
said I you know my idea is we get
married I'm all-in all my resources as
far as income and all that stuff kids if
you don't have kids I would just say
suck it up and know and get married and
just if you're not willing to put 400
grand at risk you're not ready to get
married that's I would say that to you
if you didn't have kids you got kids and
you guys are a little older you're not
you know you're not in your 20s or
something and so yeah we're both of you
divorced before or yes yeah both
divorced before and things like that so
and so you gotta go through enough
pre-marriage counseling that she doesn't
carry her former's baggage into your
deal and vice versa right in vice versa
correct yeah so that's their tenure so
uh uh makes it harder make starter it's
a valid question in your situation Jeff
and I don't have a solid answer I would
I'll tell you after talking it through
with you I would lean towards
none no prenup that would be my leaning
but you have a valid reason to consider
it because you're right on the bubble
I generally tell people if you don't
have two million dollars or more don't
do it that's a general statement but I
reserve the right to change because this
is called the Dave Ramsey show and I
make it up every day so
you